all right people we are live i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it is december 13th 2021 we are
streaming live on rumble youtube and
blaze tv as always subscribe wherever
you like to subscribe to things and of
course you can chat with other viewers
right now at rubinreport.locals.com
we have a major
announcement today i think some of you
have long suspected this announcement
but it is a personal and professional
announcement that i am incredibly
excited to share with you momentarily
and it involves not only me and my team
but this sort of a broadly
i would say
seminal moment in kind of everything
that's going on in america uh culturally
and politically because a lot of people
are making the same types of decisions
that
that myself and david and my team have
been making over the last couple weeks
but before i get to all of that i want
to talk to you guys about cozy earth
real quick you know one of the best
things about being filmed from the waist
up is that i can look business on top
while being super super comfy down below
for those of you who have been working
from home and participating in multiple
zoom meetings over the past year you
know exactly what i mean that's why no
gift will be more appreciated this
holiday season than cozy earth sheets
pajamas or loungewear i love their
sweats actually the sweatshirts are
amazing too these things are like
bananas comfortable and breathable
they're really fantastic and that's
because they're made from super soft
viscous from highly sustainable bamboo
cozy earth's bedding and loungewear are
also temperature regulating so you'll
sleep comfortably year round it's no
wonder that cozy earth has become the
betting of choice for interior designers
and celebrities cozy earth is so
confident that you'll love their
products you can try anything risk-free
for their 100-night trial if you don't
love it return it within 100 days
absolutely free so this holiday season
give the gift that will be appreciated
every single night cozy earth bedding
and loungewear and now my audience can
save 35 on cozy earth bedding and
loungewear start your holiday shopping
early just go to cozyearth.com enter
promo code dave and save 35 hurry that's
35 off at cozyearth.com promo code dave
cozyearth.com and now back to me
okay guys this is a huge day for me i've
been uh hinting to you guys for probably
about a month maybe five six weeks that
some stuff is in the works here um
obviously the last couple months with
everything that's gone between uh gone
on between locals and rumble and just
some of the other stuff that i talk
about there's just been a lot going on i
think everyone all over the country and
all over the world really
people are trying to make decisions for
themselves and their family
that are
you know basically trying to set up a
better future because everything feels
very upside down right now
so i'll give you the the bumper sticker
uh announcement right now and then i'm
going to go into some of my thinking but
yes it is true
i am moving to the great
to the free
and the alligator filled state of
florida yes that's right we have movers
in my house
right now i'm out of here in a couple
days this has been a long time coming uh
i tried my best to save california
california does not want to be saved uh
my entire team connor you're still
coming connor's coming i got the thumbs
up michael you're still coming miami
mike's coming my entire team is moving
to florida with me this was no
easy feat but everyone's excited to get
the hell out of here and go to a place
where our talents and skills and
passions will be rewarded and a place
that is more in line with the things
that we believe
by the way uh i have to give a specific
a shout out right now to dennis prager
because i had a bunch of my last
remaining la friends over for dinner
last night including dennis prager and
larry elder and a bunch of other people
and uh dennis apparently already
announced this morning on his radio show
that i was moving to florida so if you
if you were listening to dennis prager
this morning you already heard it uh but
that's all good dennis that's all good
you're still welcome to come over once
i'm in florida um look there were a lot
a lot a lot a lot a lot of reasons for
this so i want to just first recap a
little bit about my adventure
here in california you know david and i
moved to california in february of 2013
so basically nine years ago and the two
of us had i kid you not we probably
between us had about fifteen thousand
dollars and we didn't know exactly what
we were going to do i had this show on
the young turks they paid us i think
they paid me a thousand dollars a month
if i'm not mistaken and david didn't get
paid at all but we started doing it
things started working a little bit more
you know obviously we eventually
left there i was at aura tv for a little
while which was larry king's digital
network i started going independent on
patreon i built locals i just started
doing all these things our success kept
growing you know good things happen i
wrote the book the show kept moving
along i toured with jordan peterson like
i feel like i actually did what people
come to la to do like it's the story
that you want to hear it's the story
that is like the fun one like i we came
with really nothing with just sort of
this like sort of dream of oh i'm gonna
do some kind of political show and maybe
it'll become something and then we just
made the right decisions uh along the
way i guess not everyone was exactly
right but things pretty much worked out
well to the point that as i leave
los angeles this week you know we've got
two successful businesses i've got a
great team a great staff we've built
something really good and relevant i
feel like i'm probably doing the best
work in my life i love what i'm doing i
love the people that i work with like
i think this is what it's all about so
we did we did everything you could do
here and you know the funny thing about
l.a
is that you know we can all sort of joke
about california people are in la people
in hollywood and all that but like in
its best sense like there is something
cool a little bit about like some some
celebrity kind of thing and going to
restaurants and recognizing people and
that thing that is here there's
something kind of cool about it not i'm
not saying it's like the most important
thing uh the obsession with celebrity
and all of that but there was something
cool in la for for a while and it was
kind of working and you know california
was kind of working and yeah the taxes
were high but it was like you pay the
high taxes because you know the weather
is great and they have cool architecture
for the houses or whatever it might be
there's good museums and there's good
restaurants and all that stuff but what
has happened over the last couple years
here in california and specifically in
los angeles is that it is crumbling it
is absolutely crumbling here crime is up
drug use is up the streets look like
[ __ ] the schools are floundering you
know we know critical race theory isn't
everywhere the lockdowns the race riots
which when they started you know what
was it a year and a half ago
one of the major
major riots and and just mobs of people
basically went right by our house there
were people that knew where i lived and
we were getting death threats and and
people were stealing our mail and like
all kinds of stuff so we did move like i
so at that point a year and a half ago i
was thinking about
moving just getting out all together but
i thought let me just maybe move to a
little bit of a better area here i want
to fight i want to fight you guys all
know the story about how i sat down with
michael knowles at my house over dinner
with david and michael's wife and we sat
down and we said we're going to stay
here and fight that it's worth it's
worth it like
like we can't just give up on america we
can't just give up on states and then of
course what happened was the next day it
was announced the daily wire was moving
to nashville and knowles was like ah
sorry i didn't know and i was like you
know i will stay and fight and i i
fought as hard as i could for that
recall to get all those signatures
signed at the height of the lockdowns
when they didn't want people outside and
i was out there having events where you
had to hand sign the recall and uh meet
all these people and i protested at that
woman sheila cool who was the the city
councilwoman who was the 3-2 deciding
vote to close down outdoor eating while
that very night she went out to eat
outdoors at her favorite italian
restaurant in santa monica i protested
there and i just tried everything that i
could do i really did and then of course
the recall election came around and and
this guy larry elder larry elder who is
not only a friend and i would say a
mentor
of mine but like somebody who
reluctantly wanted to get into politics
to to fix this thing this isn't a guy
who thinks the government's supposed to
do everything but it is a guy who was
born here who loves this city who loves
this state who basically said hey no one
else is going to fix it i'll try to fix
it and then you know i was obviously
heavily involved with larry and i
campaigned with larry i think we've got
some pictures and some video of
being out there with larry and
interviewing him and all that stuff and
i met i met thousands and thousands of
great people and they were waving
american flags and talking about freedom
and don't tread on me and all that stuff
and before that i had been to trump
rallies here in beverly hills that were
the most joyous
wonderful things and that election
didn't turn out the way that we would
have liked and and obviously the recall
didn't turn out the way we would have
liked and and to the recall point
you know we watched the entire machine
the entire
national machine come crashing down on
larry not only did guys like reed
hastings the netflix ceo pump millions
into ads basically calling larry a white
supremacist but l.a times said he was
the black face of white supremacy joe
biden showed up a day before
the recall
to
say that larry elder was a trump clone a
guy who was born son of a janitor in
south central l.a like the evil the way
gavin newsom lied about him gavin newsom
who last week literally took a 200 000
vacation in cabo
with his family uh the same guy who of
course ate at french laundry yeah there
he is sitting with lobbyists at french
laundry at the at the height of the
lockdowns so look i could go on and on
and i really could i could go on and on
about all the things that are wrong here
and you all know it there's vaccine
passports everywhere when i i don't go
out that often you know it's really
funny my life in the last
two years since this all has begun has
been pretty great because i have a great
home life and i have good friends and we
like to host and we got a great dog and
we i got a basketball court in the back
and like we've lived a great life but i
don't really leave my house i don't
really leave my house because i can't
stand going out and seeing these masked
people you go to the supermarket and two
years later they're all wearing masks
and they're glossed over in the eyes and
there's no talk of could we take the
masks off and even david who's like the
most tolerant person on earth when we
would go to the supermarket together and
i wouldn't be wearing a mask and people
would be yelling at me and david would
be like maybe i'll just do the shopping
without you because he doesn't want to
be yelled at and i can't blame him for
that you know like i just can't take it
anymore i honestly can't take it i just
i can't take it and i won't take it um
so i'll talk a little bit more about
florida in just a second and some of
what we're going to be doing
but i just want to run through michael
back up on that for just a sec would you
i just want to run through a couple
other things that are just wrong with
california real quick first we have the
top top marginal income tax rate
in the country at
13.3 percent which uh legislators here
now want to raise to 17 we have seven
percent sales tax our gas tax is 50
cents and now they are trying to push
through something called ab2088
which would be a retroactive tax and an
exit tax for rich california residents
who leave okay that means they want to
tax you for leaving they stole all that
stuff from you in the first place and
now they want more because you make the
decision
to leave california is the most
regulated city or state in the country
with la being probably the most
regulated city within the state um
that's according to ceo magazine survey
of 650 ceos there's a massive housing
crisis here the median home cost uh in
california is 600 000
the average rent is 2 800 and to compare
that to the national average of rent
it's sixteen hundred dollars like that's
a huge huge amount just in the last
couple days california has added more
crazy things gavin newsom basically
wants this place to be an abortion
sanctuary it doesn't matter where you
fall on the pro-life or pro-choice side
of things but the idea that they want to
put more public money into
you know basically allowing more people
to have abortions here is just bananas
like it's just never going to stop here
uh there are over 150 000 homeless
people in california which is more than
any other state i get it it's a big
geographic state but you can go under
virtually any underpass here any major
roadway there are tent cities and then
they sometimes move them and disappear
and then they go on the other side of
the street and then they come back
i can talk to you about human poop on
the streets the trash cans that are
overflowing everywhere on my main street
over here which is supposedly in a nice
area and trash cans that just don't get
picked up uh violent crime is spiking
everywhere you know all the stuff about
the da's we've got this guy george
gascon who is the d.a
in uh san francisco he ruined san
francisco and turned it into a dystopian
nightmare so what happens in progressive
politics you succeed now you move down
to la you ruin it here you're allowed to
steal up to 950 dollars worth of stuff
and they're not going to prosecute you
we release criminals back on the streets
all the covid lockdowns you get it and
then the list of course of people who
have left california whether it's ben
shapiro or the daily wire who took a
hundred people
a hundred people
and moved their company out and i don't
live too far from where the
the daily wire offices used to be and
now it's just nothing it's just nothing
it's just a boarded up building there
was a thriving business with about 100
people that used to work there it is
absolutely nothing so ben shapiro all of
daily wire left ben shapiro who i
believe was born in california wanted to
live here his whole life uh joe rogan
left you think that guy makes a little
bit of money that maybe gavin newsom
would have wanted on those income taxes
elon musk left
bringing tesla headquarters with them
there's a lot of reasons to not be here
and
i tried i really like i gave it the old
college try you know like i really
wanted to fight for something i didn't
realize until the last year of my life
that i'm a fighter you know i don't
think of myself as a fighter in a
certain way like i'm i'm a pretty like
you know
i'm pretty like lukewarm guy like this
is me the same guy that you see on
camera is the same guy that i am off
camera like i'm not somebody that wants
to get in people's faces and be
screaming at him and everything but i
realized that this country is slipping
away and i live in the epicenter of it
and these people want more thank you sir
may i have another can we be in endless
lockdowns can we be an endless masks
forever can we teach our children racism
can we teach them that gender doesn't
mean anything all these things these
people all want more there's virtually
no pushback here anymore and then of
course as the country started opening up
again i took some trips and i went to
places like dallas texas and i went to
places like houston texas and i went to
places like nashville tennessee and i'll
get to florida in just a moment and i
saw free people i saw people fighting
back and that doesn't mean that there
was no one wearing masks sometimes there
are sometimes you go into a place people
make decisions for themselves but i saw
people smiling you don't see anyone
smiling in this town because you can't
even see their freaking face okay um and
i started seeing some of that and then
we went to florida for a couple of times
i had a couple speaking gigs
as you know
we moved locals down to florida last
year anyway we moved locals to miami
i met and interviewed mayor suarez down
there francis suarez there we did that
interview on location in miami and i
remember sitting there with him at that
very moment
this is probably about a year ago now uh
if not even more when was that can we
get a date on that that was yeah it was
last summer um and i remember sitting
there with him thinking man
i like this guy like he's a decent dude
and he's trying to like bring people to
his city because he loves his city and
he wants businesses to be there and all
of the people from silicon valley are
flocking and flooding
miami right now they're all showing up
and they're building huge businesses
there so we moved locals down there
i think i mentioned on the show last
week that when i was in miami last week
and i was there for house inspections
i'll get more to that get more on that
in just a second um we are not only
building offices there but we're
building a studio there like a studio so
that all locals creators can come to our
studio film whatever they want we have
flourishing business there and speaking
of flourishing businesses rumble which
as you know we merged with on the local
side they're building massive
headquarters in sarasota which is on the
west coast of florida there's no income
tax in florida so businesses want to be
there they want to flourish you know one
of the things i was worried about when i
decided to really you know make this
decision in effect and sit down with
david and say this is what i want to do
and with this we got a lot of stuff
going on our lives and we have people
that work for us and everything we were
worried like well our is our team going
to come with us and it was like
everybody was just like yeah
yeah we're coming with you we want to
get the hell out of here something
something ain't right here uh so there's
there's uh francis suarez down in miami
who's doing great work and then of
course there's ron desantis who has
become i would say the standard bearer
of what a politician should be in
america he has relentlessly fought to
keep his state open there i had dinner
with him about a month and a half ago in
san francisco and i i watched this guy
with no notes no script speak in front
of about 200 people
and and speak from the heart and answer
every freaking question and then i was
at a private dinner with him where i sat
right next to him i asked him several
questions throughout the evening he kind
of held court and this is a guy who
doesn't pretend he knows everything but
he knows an awful lot about freedom he
knows how to keep people thriving and
happy and like i want to be in a place
where i'm not just surviving but
thriving that's the truth
and i've even felt you know doing this
show when when we do this show every day
and i always say to you guys you know i
don't want to leave you depressed i
don't want to leave you more angry or
outraged or any of that stuff it's like
many mornings we're going through the
stories and i'm looking at stuff and i'm
like man this other ridiculous thing
happened in california and michael sends
me something oh see what california did
now oh see what gavin newsom did now and
it's like
i just don't care anymore i don't care
to be part of it anymore and by the way
i was at a huge huge holiday party on
saturday night about 4 500 people
at this uh at a private house and
everyone there every single person that
i spoke to was talking about leaving
every single person now i get it that
may be in a self-selected group of
people that i hang with but everybody's
talking about getting out i had as i
mentioned i had dinner with dennis
prager last night and larry elder and
their wives and a few other people and
everyone's talking about it no one
thinks this thing can be saved and the
question always comes down to well okay
how much further can it fall what would
rock bottom look like i don't know i
don't want to wait to find out for the
market to completely crash or for a mob
to show up at my house or for a homeless
person to just have an encampment
at my gate it's time to go so now uh
let's shift to the fun part of this so
yes we are moving to florida we're
moving to the miami area
we are going to build awesome new
studios we are setting them up right now
we got a house i'm super psyched i still
got a basketball court so i'm very happy
and we are going to move to a state that
is open that is free that has no state
taxes miami has all sorts of benefits if
you move your companies there there's a
ton of crazy stuff going on on that
front there's virtually no homelessness
it's clean housing is cheaper there's
less regulation the whole thing there is
a great network of people you know the
funny thing is even though a lot of my
friends have left l.a
we still have a lot of good friends here
but many people have now started
shifting down there uh there are tons of
incentives if you're watching this and
you're a business person especially if
you're in tech but if you're any sort of
business person there are huge amounts
of incentives to move your companies
down to miami if you open up offices
they'll give you extra money this is
suarez is how can i help campaign
they're doing a ton of stuff and on the
security side desantis is backing the
police and state defense not defunding
it he's even offering officers who are
resigning
in other cities so if you're resigning
in minneapolis you're resigning in
seattle or portland he's offering
bonuses i think two thousand dollar
bonuses if you will move to florida it
it's pretty freaking spectacular so we
are going to build new studios okay
we are going to expand the show we have
all sorts of plans we're going to be
hiring down there um we've gone a couple
times over the last couple weeks uh my
guys found apartments and like we're
just we're going to live a life that is
full because it's something's missing
here you're you're not supposed to live
in a place that is completely
antithetical to your world view and how
often could i sit here and say to you
you know one of the beautiful things
about america is states rights and you
have the foot vote you have the ability
to say
to
a state hey you are out of line with
what i believe i don't want to fund my
demise that's what it's felt like to me
for the last couple months i have felt
like i am funding my demise i am paying
you people an awful lot of taxes to do
things that are completely against
everything that i believe in and i just
won't do it anymore so
i'm thrilled actually like i am i am
it's been weird i'm feeling a little
weird at the moment because i got
about 10 guys moving stuff out of the
house at the moment we got a big
truck outside like we are out of here in
a couple days and i you know it's funny
i love this house people come into this
house this could have been the house
that i would have lived the rest of my
life and i could have been buried in the
backyard we have we have had wonderful
parties here and amazing people here and
it was it was uh
it was sort of a tangible proof of of my
life's work that it all kind of came
together
but now it's time for something much
better and i also i think
in terms of the show and in terms of
creativity you know as i said i i look
at these notes and i'm like i gotta talk
about california but it's like no not
only am i not gonna really talk about it
anymore but i'm going to do everything i
can and i really really mean this i am
going to devote my life now going
forward uh you know i think i've tried
to defend freedom i've tried to defend
america and everything else but america
is splitting in different ways and
that's okay that's what federalism is
that's what states are there for we are
the united states i don't know how long
we will be united for but i want to be
in a place that is in line with what i
believe and i will devote
the rest of my life as long as i'm doing
this show or anything in this space or
whatever i may do after this i'm going
to devote
my passion and my energy and my time
to saving florida which by extension is
saving the united states of america and
and
that's what i'm going to do and i'm
gonna make and i'm gonna do that by
making sure that the place i live in uh
lives up to the ideals that i'm moving
there for in the first place and i know
that more and more of you want that and
and maybe we all just have to maybe it's
decision time maybe it's finally
decision time like that's what it came
down to me it was just decision time i
remember i was on uh
tucker maybe it was like a month ago or
a month and a half ago and we were just
doing like the usual recap of stories of
like how horrible it is in la and the
violence and the broken windows and all
the stuff
and he said to me something like so what
are you doing there and it's like it's i
it felt very thin to me what am i doing
here well the weather's nice
all right the weather's pretty good in
florida for about eight months out of
the year does it get hot does it get hot
in the summer it does is the humidity
going to flatten my hair a little bit it
will will i live i think so oh by the
way i didn't i didn't know if i was
going to mention this or not but you
know what we're doing it so let's just
do it
uh
after the california recall just a few
days after the california recall
i was also audited by the state of
california okay i wasn't sure i was
going to publicly announce that but
we're doing it all right let's do it
yeah i was audited by the state of
california now my stuff is clean i've
got great business managers we don't
mess around we're totally legit
but do you think maybe that was
political retribution
do you think maybe it was just like lois
lerner the former head of the irs was
doing political retribution to some tea
party groups under obama that's what
leftists do
that's what these people do uh so yeah
they they checked all of our books three
years of my amazon purchases so there is
some schmuck government official
somewhere in sacramento who knows how
much hairspray i buy okay these people
are not good they are not good and i'm
not here to jail them i'm not here to uh
i'm not even here to scold them i'm here
to say goodbye to them that is what i am
gonna do so i i am just
i'm incredibly psyched like we're so
freaking busy at the moment as i said i
got all these people in the house and
like this wasn't this wasn't the plan
but it feels right like i i leave this
state with my head held high like i did
what you're supposed to do like you go
to where do you go in in well who knows
now but like in the old days where would
you go to make it you go to new york or
you go to la right depending on what you
wanted to do and i came here and i did
what i wanted to do uh and now i see
greener pastors and i'm gonna
i'm gonna fight man i wanna fight you
know it's one thing to fight when it's
when it's all going to [ __ ] like the the
recall thing was like man everything's
terrible here but let's fight it that's
one way of fighting and then there's
another way of fighting right there's
another way when it's like oh there's
something good here and i think often
our success i mean this in many ways is
what what america is struggling with
right now we've been so successful
for so long that we forgot we had to
fight to keep that success
and that's what i want to do now i want
to fight to make sure that there are
places places of refuge for sane decent
freedom-loving people and that's what
florida is all about and maybe i'll
become florida man maybe i'll be
wrestling alligators i think we've got a
video of a guy catching an alligator in
a garbage can that's what maybe my
future is let's take a look eugene bozzi
grabbed his trash can when he was told a
gator was lying just outside his
neighbor's front door
that's a great man that's what i want
for my future you know i mean i want to
be catching alligators in garbage cans
that would be much better to me than
living amongst these masked brainwashed
morons and it's not just him by the way
it's not just that great man eugene over
there what about the guy who saved his
dog from the alligator and he never even
got his cigar taken out of his mouth
[Applause]
this is the moment richard wilbanks
wrestles an alligator to save his dog's
life he just came out like a missile the
sound of his puppy's cries are too
upsetting so we're not sharing it
they're like children to us wilbanks
pried opened the gator's mouth and saved
his dog gunner he had one little
puncture wound my hands were just chewed
up like that's a better man than anyone
that lives in this godforsaken hellhole
really and then i thought okay maybe i
have a thing for alligators i've always
dug alligators i really have conor can
we pull it up these two photographs
that's my studio right there i got those
these are huge they're like three foot
by six foot amazing images of that a guy
down in southwest florida who i met does
these pictures where he gets in the
water with gators and what you're seeing
there it looks like you're looking at
one gator in each picture it's actually
a reflection of the water because he
gets in there with the gators so i've
had these two giant alligator
pictures photographs staring at me this
entire time so maybe florida has been
calling to me in a very deep way so i
i'm just so excited i cannot wait like i
am getting i'm getting on a private
plane too david i've been on a private
plane once but david's getting on a
private plane for the first time clyde
is getting on a private plane we've got
a friend who's hooking us up and i feel
like i'm escaping i i honestly feel like
i'm escaping
a dystopian hell hole oh i also want to
say i'm going to take a couple comments
and questions from the locals community
and then tomorrow actually
will be our last show in this studio
right after the live show tomorrow which
we'll do as a full q a because i'm sure
you guys have a million questions we are
disassembling this entire thing and then
we're out of here uh so what that does
mean in terms of the show let me just
knock out some of the logistical stuff
um we will not have any studio shows
until the new year i have to get to
florida it's going to take us a little
bit of time uh to to build until we get
to what do we think probably around
january 3rd or so yeah uh till the new
year um it's going to take us a while to
build out the studio we are going to
spare no expense i'm going to pour a ton
of money into it i'm thrilled to do it
we're going to save a crazy amount of
money in taxes like i looked at the
numbers i'm going to save so much money
that i am going to do all sorts of
things we are going to hire more people
we are going to build more stuff uh you
guys want more money you guys want more
you can you guys can have more money mr
i got a tesla the other day not bad over
there um so anyway so we won't have any
more live shows uh in 2021 however when
i get to florida i'll probably do some
stuff some handheld stuff and i'll do a
bunch more on on locals but we'll be
shutting down the studio stuff just
while we build it out i assure you this
will not be a vacation for me it will be
it will be busier than uh than ever
before then we'll probably have a
makeshift studio
in my office uh once we're in florida
for a little bit as we build out uh this
new studio which i'm just super psyched
about and and i'm not kidding we will
pour every dime into this thing to make
it the best freaking thing possible and
uh and then i think really like like on
the creative front when i talk about how
it's like one thing when you're fighting
in a place and you're you're the
outsider because the whole place is
going to [ __ ] that's what i've been
doing here in california i think as a
guy that will fight for a place that i
want to be in
um i think it's going to unleash all
sorts of like new creative stuff and fun
stuff that we can do for the show and
not feel like you know that commercial
that commercial where these people are
depressed and they've got the cloud
following them do you guys know what
depression medicine that's for there's
something and there's this woman and
she's walking around there's a cartoon
cloud always following her like i feel
like i've had a degree of that you know
what i mean like i'm a pretty happy guy
i really am i as i said i enjoy my life
like we we do good things around here
and we eat good food and all that stuff
but like there's been this thing
following me and it's like this gavin
newsom california evil monster and it's
just been like floating around following
me and i just have no doubt that i'm on
a list with this [ __ ] guy you know
like there's just no doubt like i tried
to take him out and he is an evil
psychopath gavin newsom i don't want to
live
anywhere near him anywhere near him the
same guy by the way who not only did he
go on that 200 000 vacation after he
declared a state of emergency but he
spent last week promoting his children's
book on the view even though he extended
his emergency powers but but the point
is i don't want to talk about that [ __ ]
anymore i don't think he's a good person
and i do want to say something
specifically to uh to all of the people
that i have met here in los angeles so
this is specifically really to the to
the locals community because we've done
a whole bunch of of live meetups and we
did an event at uh at a bar at pineapple
hill the night of the recall election
and i did a couple other events where
people showed up and we did we went down
to oc and we were at uh slapfish which
is andrew grules restaurant i've met so
many of you and i mean this not only to
the locals people just anyone that i've
met on the streets here or at the
restaurants or wherever it is like yes
there are good people here my neighbor
two blocks away who has a giant let's go
brandon flag outside of her house okay
right in front of her front door a huge
one right and this woman came up to me
one day and she's going on and on here
maybe you're watching i'm sorry i can't
remember your name but you like going on
and on about how much she loves me and
she goes dave you got to walk over to my
house i'm a block away and we got this
huge let's go and it's like you are a
brave person you are a good person and
maybe you'll leave too so to all of the
people that that i'm sure some of you
are are
in california right now and you're
disappointed or you're some of the
people that we've got a great group of
people in oc who come to all my events
and it's like
i will blaze a trail i will blaze a
trail so that you guys can leave too
because it's not going to get better
here for a while it will get better
eventually it really will because all of
these things are cyclical but it's going
to get much worse first and that's
that's just the depressing truth uh but
what i plan on doing is continuing to
build thriving businesses continuing to
hire people based on skill and talent
and passion and and be a refuge i i
don't know what else i want to start
maybe a non-profit to help people move
to places like this um but you have to
make sure you can't take your idiotic
lefty policies and vote for democrats
like it's just how it is it's just how
it is so anyway i'm excited because i
feel like once i'm in a place that i'm
fighting for i just think it'll open up
all sorts of creative bounds i'll go out
to eat again i don't go out to eat now
david is a great chef but it will be
nice to have someone outside of my
family cook every now and again like we
went to some great restaurants when we
were in miami there's a there's a food
scene that's blowing up they just had
art basel
last week and it's happening all over
florida and i'm gonna wrestle alligators
and the whole thing
i'm psyched i really am psyched i'm
really psyched guys um all right let me
take a couple comments and questions
from from locals and then as i said
tomorrow same time usual time will be a
full q a and then we pack up everything
and we get the hell out of here and i'll
try to keep you guys abreast over the
next couple weeks as as things go but
this is a long time this is a long time
coming um
and i will say also that it was sort of
hard for me you know i made this
decision i just moved quick on decisions
like i don't like overthinking things i
to me it's like if you if you just feel
that you should do something you got to
just weigh the pros and cons but you got
to kind of do it pretty quick you can't
do everything just like willy-nilly like
now i'm doing it and that's it you know
the hell with the rest of you but like i
just make decisions pretty quick like
i'm the decider that's the way i am in
my life and it's like that works
sometimes and it doesn't work sometimes
but it usually does work and uh and
david has to deal with a lot of the
nitty-gritty so he's out there
coordinating with a lot of movers right
now and there's all sorts of stuff
because we got we got studio equipment
and there's insurance and we you know
there's just stuff
but you know for the last month or so
where i've known that that we were doing
this and we were selling this house
obviously and buying another house and i
was there for inspections and all that
it did make it a little difficult a
little more difficult i would say to do
this show because i try to be as honest
with you guys as i possibly can be and i
just didn't want to jump the gun on
anything we were hung up in escrow for a
little bit the inspection stuff like all
of that oh i'll also say something else
about the real estate market over there
i briefly touched on housing and uh and
renting and that kind of thing the
market in cal in florida is insane
in saying the house prices are crazy
people are saying that they're sometimes
30 to 40 over because everyone's moving
there as a matter of fact the movers we
have a great moving company
the movers i sat down with the ceo to
talk to him about what we were doing and
we got a few other things i'm moving a
lot of people and he said to me that
their biggest problem right now and this
is industry-wide if you're a mover
is that normally in normal times before
the pandemic they would basically be
moving people all over the country at
all times so if somebody left california
and was moving to florida let's say you
would get them to florida all their
stuff and then there would be someone in
florida maybe moving somewhere else then
maybe they'd be moving to texas maybe
they'd be moving to colorado or maybe
they'd be moving to california so you'd
have a truck full with stuff make a lot
of money it would get there you'd get
rid of the stuff you'd put new stuff on
make more money go somewhere else he
said now people are only moving to texas
and to florida and to tennessee and
mostly to florida so what's happening is
he's got all of these trucks that are
basically going one way he makes the
money and then he has to send them back
empty because nobody's leaving over
there like what does that tell you
california had its first net loss of
population ever last year and i suspect
they when the numbers come in they'll
have their second one in this coming
year so
it's uh
at some point the rubber meets the road
i guess that's what it all boils down to
you know i can sit here and i can talk
to you about all the things that i
believe in i can i can fight as much as
i can i can mock politicians and i can
make fun of the media and i can try to
bring you some
degree of truth and hopefully you can
pilfer a little sanity out of what i do
here um but
now i want to do it from florida now i
want to do it from a place that's i mean
i can feel it i can literally you know
when you're when you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing you can
literally feel it in your body i can
literally feel it in my body i am so
freaking psyched i i just can't not wait
all right let me hit a couple comments
and questions and as i said tomorrow
will be a full
q a and uh man we got a lot to do we got
a lot to do
russell says thank you to you and your
team for everything you've done for this
city
listen russell that sounds like you're
in la and i want you to think about it
too there's all sorts of great places
like maybe that's really what the future
is i know it sounds weird and scary sort
of that america won't be the america we
all knew and the united states won't
feel exactly as united but that is what
the founders intended to some degree the
federal government has become a
monstrosity that the founders were
always trying to fight states must make
decisions for themselves and
unfortunately if if it's just going to
be we're going to have some blue states
and we're going to have some red states
it's like the red states will flourish
they will have low taxes they will have
low regulation they'll let people make
decisions for themselves they'll get
better house builders because they won't
have to deal with regulations and things
so they'll have better architecture they
will have better art all of those things
they will have better music and and what
will be left in the blue states will be
a critical race theory gender queer
unicorn of a monster that will not be
able to do anything and and produce
anything good and maybe that's okay as
long as they don't sick the army on us
and i'll have to discuss that with ron
desantis cracklin says was larry elder
the last straw you know i think
when when the recall was happening
i was loving it i loved being out on the
road with him i loved fighting i really
did and i love larry and i admire him
and he was here for dinner last night as
i said and like we had a really nice
goodbye and it's like i'm probably not
coming back here anytime larry so you're
gonna have to come visit me in miami
and um
i loved every second of it and that
morning you know that morning when the
uh recall was done and i did that thing
that joke thing where i was drinking
tequila on the on the show i can tell
you now it was water most of you put it
together um you know the theater it's
the theater i was in i took an acting
class in 2011 for one week um
i was really depressed but but it wasn't
depressed like it wasn't depressed like
oh
like this is everything because i don't
think politics is everything but it was
it was really like oh there's no hope
and that's why i talk about hope so much
like you need you need some hope and by
the way there is hope in america glenn
younkin won in virginia
a federal
court stopped biden's vaccine mandates
and then the senate voted against it
kyle rittenhouse was acquitted jesse
smallette
was not acquitted
chris cuomo was booted from cnn like
there are good things happening there
are good things happening um but was
larry elder the last draw it was that
and then i got audited and i think the
audit may have been the final like
absolute straw
because it wasn't that i had anything to
hide it was like oh this is what you do
you guys really do political retribution
through the state machinery
you know like yeah i buy a lot of
hairspray and congratulations to the
california bureaucrat who knows that now
uh unicorns dances why not texas or
tennessee i strongly strongly considered
both we really did i i looked at a
couple houses in nashville you know
jordan peterson's in nashville right now
and he's freaking loving it the daily
wire guys are in nashville i had dinner
at candice owen's house a couple weeks
ago they're they're just loving it and
thriving and the people are so decent
and happy and it's open and i really do
love nashville and i intend on spending
obviously florida is closer to tennessee
so i intend on spending a little more
time there and i think it's a great
great city uh florida because you know
i'm doing the tech thing now with locals
rumble's moving to sarasota as i said we
have the locals offices in miami my
sister lives in miami my folks have a
place they're part-time in florida david
and i haven't had family in the same
state as us since we moved here in 2013
um we are working on uh expanding the
family and i hope hopefully i can have
some updates for you guys on that stuff
pretty soon but it was important us to
to be around family a little bit more
on the texas front
i really love texas i love dallas in
particular that's obviously where the
blaze is i've got some good friends
there i i
i love glenn and tyler and the whole
team over there
i talked to glenn about maybe doing it
it just
florida just was a better fit for me it
was just a better fit for me but i get
why anyone like it's a toss-up right
it's a toss-up you go in texas tennessee
florida there's a couple other states
obviously it's not just those three
states but everyone has then their own
considerations where does your family
live like
is it is it more about weather or i got
a team of people i had to talk to
everybody and i wanted everybody to be
comfortable it's like it's like the
whole thing uh kathy says are you gonna
move next door to pelosi in florida so
it's a little unclear to me whether that
story was even true or not whether she
was actually buying this 25 million
dollar house somewhere on the water in
florida but i i am not kidding when i
say i'm going to fight for florida i
don't know exactly what that means like
i don't think i'm going to be a
politician i actually think at some
level when i'm say 20 years from now
when i'm 65 and i don't want to do like
the daily grind of this anymore i can
see myself running for like the mayor of
a small town in florida i really could
see that sort of thing but i don't want
to be like a politician in in that sense
but
we need we need more better people there
and i don't think we need the pelosi's
there that's the point i don't think we
need the pelosi's and i think when i
when i say fighting for florida it's
like i want to fight so that we can make
some decisions around who can come here
i know that sounds very authoritarian i
suppose but the states that are doing it
right it's like everybody owes florida
man an apology right now right like if
you think about it over the last couple
years this meme came out of florida man
and it's just like florida man caught
doing this an alligator this and look i
was like well florida man maybe he did
know a little something too maybe
florida man realized a little something
about being a little bit different about
thinking for himself about living life
as he sees fit you know let's show that
video of the guy getting the alligator
in the
garbage can again that this guy's
amazing here's eugene eugene bazi
grabbed his trash can when he was told a
gator was lying just outside his
neighbor's front door
like i want to meet eugene i want to
take eugene out to dinner can we let's
find eugene i'm not kidding i'll have
eugene on the show like these are my
people now okay i've had who would you
rather when the [ __ ] hits the fan who
would you rather be with you would you
rather be michael's losing it over here
would you rather be with eugene and the
alligator or some
critical race theory ineffectual useless
leftist [ __ ] that i'm surrounded by
over here you think i've had enough i've
just had enough i've just had enough uh
freedom fans says this is the least
surprising announcement of the past
decade yeah look i was sending you guys
you know a couple times i sent you the
mental energy i was trying to tease it i
i knew uh if you go back into the videos
i would often when i was saying florida
i was winking at you there was a lot of
winks people picked up on it but i
didn't want to fully announce until i
knew it was fully happening and and as i
said because the real estate market
there is so nuts like buying a house and
negotiating like there's no
contingencies there this is a little bit
of insider baseball but everything's
flying off the shelves so quickly like
you find a house that's off market you
got to put in asking price you got to
basically be willing i'll get it right
now i'll do whatever you want we got to
jump through hoops let's make it happen
anyway guys i'm really excited and i
just want to say um
[Music]
you know everything that we've done here
um it's not just that i say some [ __ ]
that may or may not be interesting to
you um it's that you guys that watch
this that share these videos that talk
to your friends about it that have
purchased the book whatever it is like
you've enabled me to do this thing and
maybe by proxy
i've been able to get some of the ideas
out there that will help defend a world
that you want to live in so this is this
is a nice little give and take that we
have here and i promise you like this is
just the beginning that's what i say to
david all the time when i come up with
my crazy decisions let's leave the young
turks let's leave patreon let's leave
borrower tv let's build a tech company
uh you know let's build a home studio oh
let's let's leave california i always
say that we're just back at the
beginning again and i suspect this will
not be the last beginning you know like
we're going to build something awesome
now and it's gonna add rocket fuel to
everything we're doing and i promise you
that my my commitment uh to all the
things that i'm always talking about
will only be strengthened by this and uh
i'm super psyched to do it i'm psyched
that my team is coming with me and uh
i'm psyched that you're part of the
adventure so uh
that's it we're going you guys still
going you still coming all right they're
still coming
this is very exciting this is very
exciting uh guys my full interview with
kaylee mcenany the former white house
press secretary under donald trump is up
on youtube right now part one of my
interview with former florida
congressman alan west who is now running
for governor of the great state of texas
he is a great man like a really really
great man uh part one is up on youtube
right now the full is up at
rubenreport.locals.com
and then we'll do a full q a like
whatever you want to ask me about
absolutely anything let's talk it out uh
it will be the final show in this studio
like i didn't want to leave the studio i
love this studio this is my office like
i love i love this house i love this
studio
but it's time to go and build something
better uh oh and by the way i will be on
ben shapiro's radio show tomorrow
morning that is at 7 00 a.m i believe
pacific time if i'm not mistaken uh and
then i normally do john bachman's show
on thursdays on newsmax but i'll be
doing that tomorrow and of course
that'll all be about florida and all
that good stuff so anyway really guys i
i thank you for all the support i thank
you for being patient with us over the
next couple weeks um i'm preempting you
on that one i i hope you'll be patient
with us uh as we build out the studio as
we move um i'll send some videos i'll
post some videos of clyde on the plane
that'll be fun you know we're getting
the hell out of here we're escaping i
feel like we're escaping this is like
literally like i'm breaking out of jail
and i'm going to freedom land it feels
like i'm moving to another country
honestly that's what it feels like
that's what what i was saying to
dennis and larry and the crew last night
it's like in the old days if you were
like i'm moving to florida from
california or i'm moving to montana from
texas or i'm moving to jersey from
delaware it would be like oh okay good
for you but now it's genuinely like will
i ever see you again am i going to be
arrested if i stay that's really what it
feels like like when i said to larry
like you're gonna have to come visit me
because i ain't coming back you're like
it's not a joke
i'm not coming back i don't want to come
back there's nothing for me here
i'm gonna literally drop like gasoline
in a match off the plane and that that's
a bit you're right you're right too much
dave too much anyway guys thank you i'm
super psyched and one more show here
tomorrow and then i will see you in
florida all right ciao